the early phase datasets library
a quick overview the uglfest dataset
library
is a library that provides an api to
quickly download many public's datasets
and preprocess them in this video we'll
explore how to do that
the downloading part is easy with the
load dataset function
you can directly download and cache the
dataset from its identify on the dataset
hub
here we fetch the armor pc data set from
the crew benchmark
is a data set containing pairs of
sentences where the task is to determine
the paraphrases
the object returned by the load dataset
function is a dataset dict
which is a sort of dictionary containing
each split of our dataset
we can access each split by indexing
with its name
this split is then an instance of the
dataset class with columns
here sentence 1 sentence to label and
idx
and rose you can access a given element
by its index
the amazing thing about the urging phase
datasets library
is that everything is saved to disk
using upper sharrow
which means that even if your dataset is
huge you won't get out of run
only the elements you request are loaded
in memory
accessing a slice of your dataset is as
easy as one element
the result is when the dictionary with
lists of values for each keys
here the list of labels the list of
first sentences
and the list of second sentences the
features attribute of a data set
gives us more information about its
columns in particular
we can see here it gives us the
correspondence between the integers and
names for the labels
0 stands for net equivalent and 1 for
equivalent
to preprocess all the elements of our
data set we need to tokenize them
have a look at the video pre-processed
sentence pairs for a refresher
but you just have to send the two
sentences to the tokenizer with some
additional keyword arguments
here we indicate the maximum length of
and pad inputs shorter than this length
truncate inputs that are longer
we put all of this in a tokenized
function that we can directly apply to
all the splits in our data set with the
map method
as long as the function returns a
dictionary like object the map method
will add new columns as needed
or update existing ones
to speed up pre-processing and take
advantage of the fact that our tokenizer
is backed by rust
thanks to the kingface tokenizers
library we can process several elements
at the same time
in our tokenized function using the
patch called true argument
since the tokenizer can handle a list of
first or second sentences
the tokenize function does not need to
change from this
you can also use multiprocessing with a
map method check out its documentation
link below once this is done
we're almost ready for training we just
remove the columns we don't need anymore
with the remove columns method
rename label to labels since the model
from the transformers library expect
that
and set the output format to desired
backend torch
tensorflow or numpy if needed we can
also generate a short sample of a data
set
using the select method